you've probably heard the term Ponzi
scheme before let me write it down
Ponzi Ponzi scheme and what we're going
to do in this video is explain what it
really is you might have a sense that
some type of scam that you're taking one
person's money and giving it to another
but we're going to a tangible example of
how it actually works and right here I
have two pictures of the probably the
two most famous perpetrators of ponzi
schemes this is Charles Ponzi right here
it was obviously named after him and
then more recently this is Bernie Madoff
who pulled off probably the longest
lasting and largest Ponzi scheme of all
time who knows maybe there's a longer
lasting and larger one out there that we
had still haven't figured out yet but
this is the log the largest one to date
and Ponzi wasn't the first person to
come up with the Ponzi scheme but they
decided to name it after him because he
was the first person to really make it
famous so this mugshot was taken in the
early 1900s where he was when he was
finally caught for perpetrating his
scheme so how does it work so let's
start with some investors here we can
get rid of the pictures of these two
gentlemen so let's say that I've got a
scheme what I'm going to do is I'm going
to set up my investors so this is my
investors here these are my investors
and then let's say we have several time
periods so we can see why the investors
think at least initially that my scheme
is legitimate so let's say that this is
the time period so we have period 1
maybe this is years year 1 year 2 year 3
year 4 year 5 and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to write each investor and
I'm going to think I'm going to write
down how much money they think they have
with me the person operating the Ponzi
scheme and then I'll show you exactly
how much money I have and how I can even
get away with having the first investors
think that I'm legitimate so let's say I
have investor a so this is this is going
to be their perceived investors
perceived let me do this in a different
color and
Esther's perceived Holdings or perceived
value and over here I'm going to write
total actual value total actual total
actual value so you can imagine this is
the actual amount of cash that I have so
we have that investor a in blue and
let's say in year one he gives me
$10,000 and I say I've got a surefire
way of doubling his money in the second
year so in the second year I actually do
nothing with the money and you know I
might actually be spending it on my own
yachts and you know fancy suits and
whatnot
well let's just say I'm just keeping it
in a bank account so you know he gives
it to me ten thousand dollars and I do
nothing with that money I don't even get
interest on it's not even in a bank
account I stuff it into my mattress so
the reality is after a year it's still
only ten thousand dollars but I promised
him that I had some type of a genius
scheme that could double his money in a
year so I sent him a statement that says
that his $10,000 is now twenty thousand
dollars is now twenty thousand dollars
and I feel good about it because I know
that he's going to be so excited that
his money doubled and he's going to want
to keep his money with me because he'll
hope that it can double again and not
only he's going to do that but he's
going to go to the country club and show
off to all of his other friends how he
was able to do way better than they did
with their investments so he's going to
essentially convince other people to
join in so let's say he convinces
investor B to join in investor B looks
at the statement says hey this this this
this guy running this one he doesn't
know it's a scheme let's say he says Sal
seems to know what he's doing he doubled
investor a's money in a year I'm gonna
give him a bunch of money let's say I'm
going to give him fifteen thousand
dollars I'm going to give him fifteen
thousand dollars in year two so how much
total actual value do I have in year two
now I have the $10,000 from investor a
plus this fifteen thousand dollars so I
have the plus the fifteen thousand
dollars right there so I have a total of
twenty five thousand dollars this is the
actual amount that I have in my bank
account assuming that I'm not spending
it on my yacht or my fancy suits but the
total perceived value let me write that
down
line so total perceived total perceived
if everyone actually wanted the amount
of money that they thought they had back
I would have to pay out thirty five
thousand dollars but we know that's not
going to happen because people think I'm
such a good investor they want their
money to ride as long as possible so you
already see this discrepancy
there's only twenty five thousand
dollars in this little pile of money
that I'm collecting but people think
that there should be thirty five
thousand dollars this is their perceived
value because this guy thought his money
doubled although it didn't it just sat
there now let's say that the next year I
send them statements at look I made
super awesome investments again the
money doubled again so this guy's money
his perceived value he gets a statement
that says you now have forty thousand
dollars this guy down here investor B
gets a statement that says you now have
thirty thousand dollars and then they go
back to the Country Club and they get
investor C on board they're like look
both of us have tried out this guy he's
doubled our money two years in a row for
both of us
you probably want in on this as well as
investors he's like yeah you know my two
buddies are they look like legitimate
guys let me put my money there so he
puts in let's say you know let's it gets
bigger every time and that's usually how
these things go you know you normally
only have just three investors you'll
have hundreds investors and the more
fake positive returns you get the more
people that want to put their money in
so investor C let's say he comes in and
he puts in $20,000 $20,000 so what's the
reality let's let's focus on so there's
a perception on year three this guy just
put his twenty thousand dollars a thinks
he's got forty thousand B thinks he has
thirty thousand so the perceived value
here is forty plus thirty seventy plus
20 is ninety thousand that's the
perceived value but the actual value is
just going to be this twenty five
thousand we had in period two assuming
we didn't spend the money or do anything
with it plus the twenty thousand that
this guy just deposited so the reality
is forty five thousand dollars now let's
say that as we go from period three to
period four or let's say right when this
guy gets his statement for $40,000 and
the exact same time period that this guy
had put in his $20,000 let's say person
a he says you know what
I felt like my ride has gone long enough
I don't want to test fate let me take my
money out and you might say oh you know
the this is the the skiing will be
ruined but it's going to work because
enough money is coming in from new
investors to pay this guy off
we now have $45,000 actual value even
though the people think there's ninety
thousand so if this guy withdraws all of
his money so if he withdraws all of his
money so it goes to zero
it's a withdrawal I have the cash to pay
him I have forty five thousand dollars
even though people think there's ninety
so I subtract out $40,000 right here and
there's only five thousand dollars left
in the bank account and since this guy
withdrew his money the perceived value
add this forty thousand is no longer
there I gave the guy the cash the
perceived value now is fifty thousand so
I essentially Oh people fifty thousand
dollars investors B and C think that
they have fifty thousand dollars
invested with me but the reality is that
I only have five thousand dollars in my
bank account and probably a more
realistic reality is I was probably
spending a lot of this money on my own
you know my own little luxuries the
whole time but let's continue another
way you know these guys once again this
guy not only have they doubled his money
for two years they're all at the same
Country Club this guy doubled his money
again
this guy just invest his money and now
this guy says look this scheme is
legitimate this legitimized the scheme
this is legit because look I doubled my
money for two years and I was able to
withdraw the money I was able to with
let me you know this was a withdrawal
withdrawal so he was able to withdraws
my so when he goes back to the Country
Club he guys he gives this guy and that
guy more conviction that this is all on
the up and up and then investor D will
probably jump in to his says Wow now
that he's doubled money two years in a
row I see his legitimate investor a was
able to withdraw his money I'll give a
hole I'll give even more money I'll give
a $100,000 I'll give a hundred thousand
dollars maybe this is a ton of people
who are now going to put in a hundred
thousand dollars and then the next year
I double the money again
and obviously I won't make it exactly
double I'll make it you know 40% one
year and 30% of the next year so it
doesn't look too suspicious I want to
make it look like real returns but for
the sake of our math let's say I double
it again so now and we're in year four I
this guy would do all of his money but
investor B now thinks he has sixty
thousand dollars investor B thinks he
has sixty thousand dollars investor C
thinks he has forty thousand dollars and
investor D thinks he has two hundred two
hundred thousand dollars oh and I forgot
to put investor DS deposit here so when
he put a hundred thousand dollars I only
had a five thousand in my bank account
but then if I add a hundred I'll now
have 105 in my bank account after this
guy comes in at you know the beginning
of period or at the end of period three
we could imagine and what the perceived
amount I owe is 150,000 150,000 so the
green is what happens after D comes in
so these are no longer no longer valid
but you can see that as more money comes
in I have more and more money to pay out
even though I'm not doing anything even
though all of these returns are fake so
now I actually have $105,000 even though
people think well that's at the end of
period three at the end of period four
what do people think people think that
they're that I have $300,000 of holdings
let me write that down
people think that there are $300,000 of
holdings but the reality the reality is
I still only have a hundred and five
thousand dollars of holdings 105
thousand this is the total actual value
but notice if this guy or this guy some
of the early investors wanted to pull
out some of their money although they
probably don't want to because where
else can you double your money every
year and this guy already showed that
I'm good for paying back the money but
even if this guy or this guy wanted to
pull out their money I would be able to
give it to them because I have at least
enough for those withdrawals
now everything would be ruined if
everyone gets freaked out or scared and
if if I have mass withdrawals or if more
people withdraw money than there is in
the bank plus the amount of money that
comes in so in order for a Ponzi scheme
to keep going and Bernie Madoff was able
to do this for a very long time
you have to have good believable
legitimate returns although they're not
legitimate they just need to look
legitimate so that you have more money
coming in some more in
then then out and the thing that both of
these you know the whole point of doing
this Ponzi scheme if you're you know if
you're a stylish criminal isn't just to
keep the money isn't just to keep the
cash there you know the ten thousand
dollars from one period to the next that
the whole point of it is to take a lot
of that for yourself
for you to live off of and put into some
Swiss bank account to be able to escape
the country at some point anyway
hopefully you found that enjoyable